hi my name is Magic sieminski I
represent African lions investment bank
Africa and 2010 I think it's definitely
going to be a big challenge to change
perceptions about Africa as a conductor
as the continent as a whole what we see
is that Africa is often seen as a place
where things do not work there are
problems with communications technology
and often there is a lack of manpower
but in 2010 this is great opportunity to
South Africa and the rest of the
continent to show that such a big event
can be done on such a big scale what we
have seen in this number of countries
actually working together to making the
2010 world cup economic success we for
example in Mauritius you have special
packages available where defense can
stay in that country and if you fly in
for the games we have also seen Botswana
Zambia and others hosting teams which
will be participating in the contest I
think overall this will be a great
benefit to the region and to the
continent as a whole this kind of
showpiece will hopefully change the
perceptions that many people in the
world have about the continent thank you